51 of men between the ages of 18 and 29
are single compared to 32 percent of
women in the same age group how the does
that work the gender split of men and
women is around about 50 50. well it
probably works because there's probably
small percentage of men that are dating
a lot of these women and probably
perceive that they're in a relationship
with these men when in actuality he's
probably dating a variety of different
women tied to that concept is the notion
that the reason why they're single is
primarily because they're too afraid to
ask a woman out guys using only fans
sort of takes away the sting of
rejection when there are masters at
spotting they can see it a mile
away especially when it comes to
romantic conquest and if a man is not
genuine in his intentions she's going to
spot that very very quickly